because our culture places such a high
value on sociability it can be deeply
awkward to have to explain how much at
certain points we just need to be alone
we may try to pass off our desire as
something work-related people generally
understand and need to finish off a
project but in truth it's a far less
respectable and far more profound desire
that may be driving us on unless we're
alone we feel at risk of forgetting who
we are we the ones who are asphyxiated
without periods by ourselves take other
people very seriously perhaps more
seriously than those in the
uncomplicated ranks of the endlessly
gregarious we listen closely to stories
we give ourselves to others we respond
with emotion and empathy but as a result
we cannot keep swimming in company
indefinitely at a certain point we've
had enough of conversations that take us
away from our own thought processes
enough of external demands that stop us
heating our inner tremors enough of the
pressure for superficial cheerfulness
that denies the legitimacy of our latent
inner melancholy and enough of robust
common-sense that flattens our
peculiarities and less well charted
appetites we need to be alone because
life among other people unfolds too
quickly the pace is relentless the jokes
the insights the excitements there can
sometimes be enough in five minutes of
social life to take up an hour of
analysis it's a quirk of our minds that
not every emotion that impacts us is at
once fully acknowledged understood or
even as it were truly felt after time
among other people there are a myriad of
sensations that exist in an unprocessed
form within us perhaps an idea that
someone raised made us anxious prompting
vague impulses for changes in our lives
perhaps an anecdote sparked off an
envious ambition that's worth decoding
and listening to in order to grow
maybe someone subtly fired
aggressive darted us and we haven't had
the chance to realize we're hurt we need
some quiet time to console ourselves by
formulating an explanation of where the
nastiness might have come from we are
far more vulnerable and tender skinned
than we're encouraged to imagine by
retreating into ourselves it looks as if
we are the enemies of other people but
our solitary moments are in reality a
homage to the richness of social
existence unless we've had time to be
alone we can't be who we'd like to be
around our fellow humans we won't have
original opinions we won't have lively
and authentic perspectives we'll be in
the wrong way a bit like everyone else
we're drawn to solitude not because we
despise humanity but because we are
properly responsive to what the company
of others entails extensive stretches of
being alone may in reality be a
precondition for knowing how to be a
better friend and a properly attentive
companion
our comm prompt cards can help us to
find serenity despite daily anxieties
and frustrations to find out more click
on the link now
you